si je vous demande à vous quels sont les
pires animateurs bah oui les petites 104
m'étais bien regardant à très gentil
s'était alors on va commencer par alors
alors maïali donc vous c'est qui et
shy'm à la chanteuse non plus en fait
depuis quelques jours et de l'animation
ces catastrophes on la voit plus fins
qu'un cheveu star de la télé présentée
danse avec les stars j'avoue j'en ai pas
gardé un super souvenir
il est très bon comédien mais allez
matters est pas pour l'été dans la drôme
non ouais c'est ça mais c'était co
animateur avec sandrine quétier hughes
et des eaux c'est vraiment parce qu'il
fallait trouver quelqu'un trouve pas
terrible mais bon j'aime quand on sent
qu'on lui a arraché mon nom mais j'aime
bien j'aime pas casser les très très
bien vous c'est alors moi camille
lacourt tout simplement parce que je les
rencontre plusieurs fois pour son
bouquin son dernier bouquin n'a pas fait
la paix il est tellement timide que pour
présenter une émission de télé je le
vois mal certes c'est un beau gosse etc
mais présentait l'émission des valides
sur l'épaule mais ses bons coups de
coeur de tout à l'heure pas maintenant
d'accord mais voilà donc j'espère qu'il
sera bon oui mais il est tellement
timide que je ne suis pas sûre d'en
faire avant excuse moi mais les images
sont même pas sortis encore qu'il est
chez vous non
[Rires]
tous les syriens
la porte arrière petite fille magali il
vous plait le camille lacourt
franchement j'aime bien il est
merveilleux ce qu'il a dit dans son
interview sur les femmes ça m'a dégoûté
aussi notamment jean réveillon les
hommes il m'énerve
les caennais je n'ose même pas vous dire
ce qu'on m'a dit dans l'oreillette on me
dit quoi alors est ce n était pas
possible c'est pas grave alors vous
lyrisme et narre une émission un
naufrage bien on sait vraiment pas ce
qu'il fallait qu'elle en fait un tout
petit peu trop quand même et les manies
faille sur joao do samba sy c'est un
personnage jmil valérie bègue et je suis
pour le fait d'oser des animateurs moi
j'ai présenté avec les fortunes roue de
la fortune qui dans mon cas était plutôt
la route de l'infortuné moi je suis
content parce que j'aime pas qu'on
laisse les gens dans les cases pourquoi
ils n'auraient pas droit d'avoir leur
chance alors tu dis 15 ans mais quinze
ans ils n'ont pas 15 ans ils viennent
d'arriver harris métissé pas des gros
programme qu'on leur donne c'est des
trucs enregistrés ils sont en direct
c'est une formation elle a répété plaza
moi j'aime beaucoup et norbert qui fait
des animations étaient cuisson est ce
que vous pensez vraiment que nous on est
chroniqueur une carrière et agile qui a
été journaliste il ya toi que vous qui
avez une carrière sinon les autres moi
j'ai une amie à mahdia rien de de
l'autoroute a6
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la vie nommé la vérité c'est au regard
du fait qu'on travaille et tu le sais
très bien très bien placé comme les gens
comme toi est ce encore plus beau comme
toi et moi qui sommes personne et on
venait à devenu parisien du sud et
aujourd'hui on est là pour donner notre
chance en l'occurrence lui l'a bien dit
on s'en fout qu'il soit pas une torche
et qu'elle parle aux gens je veux
qu'elle ait quelque chose à dire à la
télé c'est ce qu'on leur demande ce
qu'ils appellent des ornements on a
voulu voler mais c'est totalement
gratuit
oui parce que son exubérance n'exaspère
alors qu'elle est vraiment très sympa et
je trouve que c'était une chanteuse et
prennent des banlieues n'a pas reconnu
mais c'est vrai qu'en tant qu'un animal
moi j'ai du mal
alors vous n'aimez pas norbert vous ah
non c'est pas la cause qu'est ce qui
vous dérange chez norbert 7,52 pâti de
boulanger lui meilleur boulanger bon
donc chez les lébous les boulangers
c'est un cuistot c'est un showman
mais c'est pas un animateur d'entreprise
leur mère il est aussi costaud il est
plutôt pas mal dans son dans son rôle
ouais mais voilà c'est pas c'est pas la
même chose je trouve qu'il est beaucoup
plus aura tort et je trouve qu'ils
présentent plus les plutôt naturelle à
dieu je me présente mal pour vous non
c'est pas ça je trouve qu'ils voient là
il faut qu'ils restent cuissots qui
continue à faire le lit ce que c'est
devenu quelque chose assez rentré chez
moi
voilà